[Music]
this is a build for those of you who
want to play in a similar style to the
striker set but would like a little more
survivability
I don't watch build videos and I will
never claim that whatever I've built is
the best of its type as I'm a strong
believer in the fact there is no person
on the internet that can throw some
pieces together run the numbers and
decide what is the best build for your
style of play instead use what you see
here as a template and adjust it to what
works for you
this particular set I'll be running
through has a huge amount of flexibility
and can be very easy to tweak if you
want more damage or armor Etc and I'll
try to point out some examples of this
as I go
I'm not going to read through all the
set perks or each individual Talent
description in order to inflate the
length of this video but I'll have these
on screen so feel free to pause at any
moment to read through these
but in the interest of keeping these
build videos as short as possible let's
crack into it
the idea behind this build is to have a
good mix of DPS and survivability
here I am running full pieces of
Heartbreaker on the backpack chest
gloves and Holster to get the maximum
out of the set I would highly recommend
using the backpack and chest pieces for
the additional Max BPM and cold talents
which will increase the stacks you are
able to attain and their effectiveness
the mask is the catharsis exotic for a
good mix of extra damage and healing
the knee pads are the overlord armaments
Fox's prayer purely because these are
still one of the best in slot for damage
with multiplicative damage obtained
through the eight percent damage to
targets out of cover
all pieces have been rolled into armor
for the core attribute work well apart
from my knee pads and either critical
head chance or damage for the secondary
attributes
with the pieces I have at my disposal I
get around 50 critical hit chance and
100 critical hit damage
and certainly get a little higher
also this is where you have a lot of
flexibility personally for my style of
play I run this with all grids
everything into damage because in my
opinion for the higher difficulty levels
you gain dramatically higher value from
putting stats into damage than armor
however if you were of a similar mind
frame you'd probably get a lot more
enjoyment out of running Strikers as
this will put out a lot more damage than
Heartbreakers
but I digress like I said earlier this
is a template adjust everything you see
here to find that sweet spot for your
style of play
the primary weapon I'm showing here is
the king breaker named assault rifle
purely because this is the best example
of synergy between its Talent perfect
Flatline and the heartbreaker gear set
personally I prefer the non-perfect
Flatline Talent on the Famas because I'm
more of a fan of the high rate of fire
the secondary is the rock and roll named
shotgun the purpose of this weapon is
purely for gaining quick stacks and with
the increased magazine size this will
build those Heartbreaker Stacks very
quickly from there you can quickly
switch over to your primary and deal the
damage
if you're wanting to deal a bit more
damage with this weapon for example
controller players may prefer to use
this more often I'd recommend switching
for the standard acs-12 where you can
roll a talent more suited to gaining
extra damage
the specialization is gonna I'm using
this for the x-rayed of fire amaron kill
and the slow trickle of ammo that comes
through which is super handy when
playing full directives
however you may prefer to use tactician
for the laser pointer attachment that
applies a pulse effect to all enemies
that are aimed at this is particularly
good if you aren't so confident with
your aim when trying to utilize the
heartbreaker set Talent you'll also gain
that plus one skill tier which is always
useful
I'm using the reviver hive skill because
I'm usually solo and the Crusader Shield
I'm generally not a fan of using Shields
as they feel a bit cheesy to me but they
can be very useful when you first
approach hostiles and need to gain those
initial stacks
and that's it I'm more of a covered
cover player but you could technically
just face tank with this build out in
the open provided you're able to keep up
those headshots in turn giving a steady
stream of armor
like I said earlier if you prefer that
higher damage Strikers is still a better
option but if you're just after a little
more survivability this is a great set
just have a play around with the DPS to
armor ratio and find that perfect spot
for you
if I ran through this too quickly just
let me know of any questions you have in
the comments and I'll try to get back to
you
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
oh
[Music]